by this point in this class you must
have realized that a lot revolves around
the concept of conditioning conditional
expectations play a central role for
this reason it is useful to revisit this
concept and view it in a more abstract
manner the basic idea is that the value
of a conditional expectation is affected
by a random quantity by the value of the
random variable Y on which we are
conditioning it is a function of Y and
therefore a random variable based on
this observation we will redefine the
conditional expectation as a random
variable and then try to understand its
properties in particular we will develop
a formula for the expected value of the
conditional expectation this will be
what is known as the law of iterated
expectations after doing all this we
will follow a similar program for the
conditional variance once more we will
see that it can be viewed as a random
variable and then we will relate its
expected value with the unconditional
variance this will be the so-called law
of total variance as an illustration of
the tools we are introducing in this
lecture we will consider various
examples that will hopefully clarify the
concepts involved our final and most
important example will involve the sum
of a random number of independent random
variables the setting here is more
challenging than the case where we add a
fixed number of random variables but by
using conditioning we will be able to
derive formulas for the mean and the
variance